How's it going bros?
My name is Dokey Bane.
Hey guys.
Today we're going to be playing a new game that just came
out in 2012.
It's Happy Wheels.
I saw a lot of other Let's Players playing this game the
last couple of weeks.
So I decided why not, why shouldn't I check it out as well?
Happy 2012, guys.
We survived the end of the world.
Oh,
we're so back.
So cute.
Anyway, I cannot wait to check Amnesia after this, too.
All right, let me put you guys up on.
What am I talking about?
This is a Let's Play video.
I pre-recorded this.
What do you mean, chat?
There is this pre-recorded video.
There is no chat.
This is my part one of my Happy Wheels montage.
Hey, no.
I fed you.
I fed you before.
All right.
On the Doki News.
Okay.
This is not Doki News Network.
This is actually not Gadipro.
I after the tournament yesterday.
I literally just crashed out in my bed.
Like, I think I slept the entire, like I walked that and
then just slept the entire day.
I woke up around, okay, this, okay, okay, do not be, okay, I
know you guys, okay, I'm going to say this, and you guys are
going to be so concerned.
And you're going to be like, are you okay?
Okay, I'm okay right now.
But I woke up at like 10 in the morning.
And then I don't know, what the, I don't know.
I think it was from all the stress and everything.
It just built up because like I said, it was like I spent
like 20 plus hours in the last three days, the last three
days before the tournament or like finishing up organizing
everything.
And I was so stressed out.
And at 10 in the morning today, I woke up and felt something
like I didn't feel sick.
The thing is, I didn't feel sick at all.
And then I just threw up randomly.
Like I could feel it.
And I was like, oh, shit.
And then like instantly got up and went straight to the
bathroom and just threw up.
and then and i went and then like you know my throat was
burning and it was like something something super acidic
because um my throat was burning a lot and then when i was
like um trying to get like there was like stuff in my throat
and i was like i don't know what this is like wow like you
know when you're like trying to get something out of your
throat um there's like a word for it but i don't know how
what's like the process of that is and um there was i think
there was there was food um and um and when i was like oh
give me you put the alert somewhere else the alert maybe
i'll put it here uh anyway um and there was like blood in my
throat but i think it was just because like it it like was
uh there was like i don't think it was like nothing to be
too concerned because it was it's okay now because i woke up
and it's okay now there's no um and um because i had like
stuff like and then uh because when i was like i felt like
stuff in my throat and i was like trying to get it out and i
was like like And, you know, I don't want to make the sound.
And I think, like, the, I think, like, the acidic, um, um,
what's the word?
The acidic, uh, uh, tear it a little bit of it.
And then, uh, yeah, I was hacking up some gunk.
In my throat.
And people, like, when I threw it up, there was no blood.
So I was just, I was like, it's okay.
So I think it's just, like, the tear.
Like, it was just the acidic and the burns, like, burned a
little bit of my throat and tear it a little bit.
But it's okay now.
Because I checked it this.
Like, when I woke up again, I checked it again.
And it's fine.
It's fine now.
So, I think it was from, yeah, it's from all that stress
from it.
And then, like, oh, my God, the other alert's still here.
Let me put this.
Let me put it.
Move this down to whoops.
Yeah, Alan, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Stress can build up acid in your stomach.
Plus the fact that you eat very regularly from what you see
is checks out.
Think of the super chat.
Think of the thing.
Yeah.
Patra, I see the super chat.
Do you think?
Yeah.
Curse of Apex.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, it was just, I'm okay now.
Like I legit felt, did not feel sick at all.
That was the biggest like question mark for me.
Because I thought I was like, oh, did I get food?
literally pre vomit and pre and after vomit i did not feel
sick at all like literally after i threw up i just went back
to sleep and i was okay like i i did not feel anything wrong
and i just went back to sleep and passed out and like pre
also like before it was just uh i didn't feel like anything
and it's just i woke up and i was just like it like a slow
build it was like like it like huh something feels like not
slow so it was a fast build i was like oh i feel weird and
then i was like oh and then i went ran straight to the
bathroom yeah basically um that's basically like what what
went through i just think i was just i was i was so stressed
out i'm i think like like putting together turn it within a
week all right you guys have no idea like um i was not
allowed to change the rules retroactively like on the fly
for the tournament um everything that was written out we had
to like just go through with it like we could not like i
wanted to change the rules um as we went on um but i
couldn't do it because it was just like uh legally wise like
it was all written out so i couldn't like change anything i
was like because i wanted to add like i wanted to like
adjust the game modes and stuff after uh not even minimal
changes it had to be followed the that was written out on
the tournament.
So I would have, you know what I was like, they took my
power.
Like it's my executive, my power stops here.
Like, yeah.
So there were moments where I wanted to change some of the,
like change some of the game modes, like as we went on the
fly as we went on because I wanted to like maybe change it
to balance it a bit more.
But we couldn't do it just because like per rule, like it
has to be, done as per written in the rules um so that was
like what like it was like by the book yeah so it was like
like there's stuff like that that was just like oh if only i
could change it but i couldn't like i couldn't change it
anyway but i i like you know within a week i i what when in
the week being able to pull that off was that just crazy i
like you guys have no idea like alterra was the only um i've
sent like so many invites like oh like to everybody um
alterra was actually his own team and uh well not originally
it was supposed to join my team and then uh some of the uh
he was going to try to see if any of the other Hall of Stars
boys wanted to join but uh none of them were available that
last minute of course none of them were available so I moved
out and then I'll tell you I was like yeah I'll be on the
team with Hall of Star Boys um uh I think I might be on the
team with Hall of Star Boys I was like okay and on the last
day the day before the tournament he was just like oh none
of them could make it can I join your team and I was like an
entire team, like a full team as well.
Because I saved that spot for HoloStars to see if like they
were able to come.
And then I'm glad Altair, he was able to do it and I moved
him to my team.
And then, because I was like doing my team last.
Because like I just want to fill up everything else and then
my team will be the last team to like compile.
So I still had one more spot.
Like it was a meme attire and I was like, all right, All
right, I'll say, pooh, you're on my team now.
Yeah.
And I just filled up the, like, another full team slot, too.
So, like, I invited, like, so many events were going on.
Like, we had a Red Bull event, and, like, a lot of the
players were at a Red, like, a lot of, like, Apex, like, the
Apex players were at it in a Red Bull event, or a Twitch
rivals thing that's going on.
And then, um, and then there were like, oh my gosh, the
amount of people I find out that the amount of people I
found out that operate or live in an area that was not, that
was that I cannot have them participate because they were
not in the, um, actual locations that they had to be.
And they would, they would be like, oh, hey, uh, Doki, I am,
I am Canadian slash American, but like right now, right now,
where I'm at is not the eligible territories of which I can
operate as per the rules sheet.
And I was just, I was just like, oh my God.
Oh, like, oh, what do you mean?
I thought you are, I thought you were Canadian.
And they're like, well, I'm Canadian, but I'm not in an area
that's, uh, right now, that's legally allowed to uh
participate as per the restrictions on on for the tournament
and i'm like oh
all right you gotta find one last guy i got one last guy
uh gus thank you mr chet thank you thank you i've seen those
shows where women wake up and go directly to the bathroom
congrats guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank
yeah there's like um so for those who are confused like uh
the tournament it's just a legal thing uh it's mostly for
like create it's for creative tournaments but uh there's uh
only uh there's like certain country restrictions and also
territory restrictions because even if you're If you live in
Quebec, you can't, if you're like, if you're, the business,
if you like currently legally live in Quebec, you're not
allowed to participate, like stuff like that.
So like Canada, even then for Canada, Quebecois not allowed
because there's a different rules.
I didn't even realize this.
I didn't even realize this, but Quebec has different rules
regarding prizes compared to the rest of Canada.
So I don't know what the rules are, but Quebec just isn't,
we're not on the same wavelength.
Quebec.
Yeah.
We're just not, apparently, I mean, we all know they're not
on the same wavelength as the rest of Canada.
But I'm just like, I'm just like, what about prize winnings?
Is it different?
Like, do you not want money, Quebec?
Oh, I think it's gambling.
Oh yeah, they considered gambling.
gaming as gambling oh yeah that's yeah yeah no that was I
remember now they're like it's because of gambling laws in
Quebec because it's considered gaming as gambling which I it
depends on the game itself I guess but I don't I think it's
a whole different area oh yeah um other than that well since
we're talking about gaming do you guys see the newest thing
that's going on they added uh they added chicks and i'm not
talking about women i you can hatch your own chicken and
it's it's a new gotcha system where you can get like chicken
eggs in the new in csgo or sorry not csgo cs uh cs2 counter
strike 2 and you can hatch different varieties of chickens
so the chickens have their own chicken skins so instead of
knife cs knives it's now see as chickens and oh yeah they're
not tradable by the way just so you know yeah they're not
tradable uh but you can now um raise and hatch your own
chickens and you can get different rarities of chickens uh
but how can i legally trade my chickens what's the point of
i can't literally trade my um my rare camo chicken all right
let me show you guys counter strike two chickens i don't
know if i don't know if i bookmarked it but um i'll show you
a series of images but there are different rarities of
chickens too uh and different skins um so you get like they
get chicken egg and all right let me see let me show an
image real quick so you get a chicken egg right here and
then through that you can raise chickens let me grab a photo
of the different types of chickens and then from there you
can start raising your chicken and you got to feed them and
you gotta take care of them and then they'll grow up to be a
chicken or a seat counter there's some crazy ones i saw
chicken skins even dokey hey that background you have i've
seen it before a fellow floor gang member to be thank you
with a super chat thank you thank you what do you mean this
is my room all right and then these are some there's some
wild ass variants too for this type of chickens oh yeah okay
so here's some different so these are default chicken you
can get but then then you can get the different rarities too
you can get the what is that specific color bearing called
like on the knives um the Doppler effect yeah you can get
Doppler chicken guys isn't that fucking crazy oh my god you
can get Doppler chicken and the fire chicken too um you can
get the the crow the marble face the chicken the the Doppler
chicken the uh the 70 words thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you I worked 50 hours at a sushi restaurant
this week my body hurts oh I hope you're feeling better 70
stories thank you super chat thank you thank you um but yeah
anyway that is gamer news for the day what else what else is
there anything else on the doki news network I think that's
really it not a very exciting week I mean to be fair I don't
know.
I don't know.
A lot of stuff has been passing through for me because I've
just been so heavily focused.
I've been so heavily focused on on the Apex tournament.
So like everything's a blur right now.
There might be a lot of news stuff that I missed out on.
But I do remember.
I do remember the chicken news though.
I do.
about the chickens uh yeah Fridays with dokeybird I mean
used to watch all those let's players in 2012 um oh my like
uh beauty I remember my friend was one that recommended me
to PewDiePie um just because like I think it was like during
and then the Nisia amnesia arc and then that's how I was
introduced to him and then you know cinnamon toast can uh
top cryotic
ah oh man oh man i actually used to watch cryotic a lot too
uh because i really enjoyed his like in the the indie horde
and whoa rest in peace uh one of the first uh google dokey
big google dokey youtubers out there the creatures i watched
creatures cow chop um um uber i i still watch uber hacks or
nova but he does a lot of gta's rp stuff and like i'm i'm
sorry for me okay i'm really bad at rp too that's why i
don't normally don't join i i no i don't i choose not to
join rp servers because i'm so bad at rp because i get like
what's the word i i i like when you're like i blank out when
it comes to rp um so like someone tries to talk to me i
blank out A lot of GTA RP is just like, one of my friends
was telling me was like, because I was just like, I don't
know.
I don't really vibe watching GTA RP or just RP stuff in
general.
Yeah, I get stage, I get stage fright.
And like, when I'm on the spot, I just blank out when it
comes to role-playing.
And I just like, I role-play as myself.
Like, I'm good at improv, but it's like improv in a way when
I'm streaming, you know um when i'm like streaming and stuff
like improvving is like fine like i can bounce off of people
but if i'm improvving uh when i'm improvving like a
character or like role play i just all i can i can improv as
myself but i can't improv as someone else uh so like i
choose not to join great at it and um and like i was telling
me and i don't like i i just don't care much about watching
rp stuff too because i just can't it just doesn't really
like click for me um and then one of my friends who who also
doesn't watch rp stuff uh but they do like dungeon and
dragons and all that and all that but like they like rp but
they don't like gtrp and they're telling me like oh i think
like the reason why is that a lot of GTRP is like, hmm,
very, uh, I guess like wagey simulator type deal, but it's
not like wagey, but it's more so like normal guy simulator,
you know, like unless you're like being a bank robber, like
a lot of like stuff that's going on sometimes in a lot of
these RP server is that not a lot of stuff is going on until
something happens, like, because you're all just walking
around, um, and yeah it's like normie normal life simulator
um and it's like yeah real life like slice of life yeah um
and like a lot of people are just walking around doing stuff
until something happens and then it gets exciting but after
that happened but you don't know when it's gonna happen and
then and then but then you have to you know you have to go
on with the day and it's like yeah um and it's basically and
and I guess that's why like I I just don't click with RP
like stream streamer games just cuz like you gotta like when
I went into rust you know like you don't know it's just like
walking around and hanging out until something happens and
then I mean to be fair I come I when I did the rust stuff I
went in like once a week and every time I logged in
something was happening but if I had to play it every day um
every day then for me it would get a lot like and I was like
you know I was like role-playing as myself too but if I had
to play every day then it would be like I don't think I
could play every day just because I just because I don't
know um because like I don't like um I don't know like how I
don't know I just I there's a lot of downtime if I played
every day but if I when I was logging in once a week
something was always happening because I was just like
everything was new.
Everything.
Yeah.
I went in.
Everything was just new.
Like something was happening.
But if I had to do it every day, I don't think that would
work as well for me.
Because I don't think that would something would be
happening every day.
Um, but yeah, no, I don't know.
I wish I was a better role player because I'm, like I said,
also, like i'm just not very good at role playing and i was
like and then that's what like that for me that's what i uh
like i'm scared to do in general so that's why you don't see
me doing a lot of like uh doing a lot of like role play
stuff or joining a lot of like streamer role play service
because like i said i know there's like there's the rough
stuff going on right now i didn't end up not doing i didn't
i'm not joining the project zone boy server that stripping
was doing because like I think by time I had lots of going
on but time was free um um the guys weren't really playing
Zomboid anymore so I was like so I was just like oh okay
it's alright and then um I know like uh and like you know
GTA RP as well and I was like oh I'm too scared of role now
I'm too scared of role playing and also embarrassed I guess
like embarrassing myself and random people's streams just
because I don't know how to role play really well
Varshan, think of a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's stay away from bridges now.
Think of a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I know it's just like practice makes perfect too.
Yeah, I get that.
I'm fine with like in a collab situation because like it's
me.
Yeah, I was like trying to talk to Newpia.
It's like, hey, hey guys, I'm the new kid at school.
I'm trying to make friends like, hey everyone.
I'm the new...
I guess I just got transferred.
yeah what's crazy is that i used to role play a lot like
growing up because i um um for those who don't know uh when
i was growing up i was on the neopets forums and there were
like there was a role play board there was a um there's like
a role play board section um in neopets and growing up um i
would like hang out on the neopets forums and i would role
play um i would like make characters and roleplay.
I remember, okay, okay, this is so, okay, I did Warrior Cats
roleplay.
Like, I would, that's how I learned to type really fast, by
the way, and come up with, like, random stories on the spot,
um, because, uh, because I said I can improv, and I can
improv and stuff, but, like, I don't, I don't know, like,
when I'm put on the spot on stream, I just can't, um, I
would roleplay Warrior Cats.
I did, like, high school roleplay.
I did, like, uh, uh gifted students like you know like uh
like like you know it's like x-men like but then they don't
use x-men they're like gifted students at school at high
school roleplay uh okay you know what's funny um i i
remember i did not know anything about harry potter um back
in the day like all i had knowledge of was like the movies
so like oh yeah like vampire roleplay but like yeah all the
only had was like the movies I watched when like at that
time they were still new so you know like movies are still
new and everything and I uh and like that was like my only
knowledge but then there was like Harry Potter role play
forms and stuff so I was like you know what like I like it
would be interesting the thing is I had no knowledge of like
like I've never read the books or anything and then it was
so funny because I didn't know it like you know all my
information was just from the uh from the movies itself and
so but it was just me remembering what happened in the
movies like what I was because like what I saw at the movie
theater and so I didn't realize what uh what was it called
the fucking train platform like I don't even remember a
doubt.
Like, so there's like, you know, like where all the students
go to for the train platform shit.
Like, I don't even, I don't remember.
So, so they, because they were setting up the scene and
stuff.
Yeah, nine and three fourth corridors or whatever.
And then I was like, hey, where's the location?
And they're like nine and three fourths.
And I was just like, I was like, wait, are we at the train
station?
Like, where is...
They're like, I was like, the scene starts at 9, and I was
like, so confused, and I was just like, uh, where are we?
Are we, like, at the train station?
They were just like, yes, we were at 9.
Yeah, I was like, yes, but like, where's that?
Is that?
Where is that?
I thought we were starting at the train station.
Uh, they're like, uh, yeah, they're like, uh, yeah, they're
like LARPERP exposed.
There's a LARP among us.
so yeah the custom larp alert there's a poser among us you
back in the day it's called posers
um yeah so i think i would do that like you know i used to
roleplay a lot but like um um i just i don't know when i'm
roleplaying on stream I blink out because like typing
something versus saying stuff and doing stuff is so
different uh those goddamn posers uh anyway today we're
gonna be playing happy wheels I can't believe it's been like
more than 10 plus years uh but the this is by the original
devs uh the original devs sorry of happy wheels I've
actually never played this game before I've only watched
people play it was a staple in the let's play community back
in the day so um i know i watched the happy wheels of
montages and everything so yeah let's let's jump right into
it let's go play some happy wheels i've never played any i
don't think i'll ever play amnesia i don't like resource
horror games i like horror games based off of resource
management i'm sorry guys
This is loud.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that game is so loud.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god, it's actually nostalgia bait right now.
Well, they're not baiting, but you know.
Technically not nostalgia bait, but I feel like.
I feel the nostalgia running in.
Okay, I can't.
Oh my god, this game is so old.
You can't even use, like, game capture.
You have to use window capture.
That's crazy.
Happy wheels.
Oh, what the fuck?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry, this was from the War Dogs era when I had to...
When I had to grab the queue.
Sorry, crazy lady.
I can't show you on screen right now.
We're not logged.
in but that's okay can I uh looks the worst but runs the
fastest where's the the original flash look this does not
improve do not enable but interpolation we'll do the
original wait is that okay graphic okay texture fps mode
what's that oh it's just that okay uh render blood settings
full screen please thank you all right we have full screen
uh all right controller options okay all right sound guy let
me know how you feel about the sound all right whoa the
original three levels oh my god they have like every wait
they actually have some of the oh like the some of the og um
oh that's crazy yet that's actually so nostalgic They have
some of the custom levels that lets players play it back in
the day.
Headshot it.
His music bug?
Comment, let's give it a super chat.
Thank you.
How's it going, bros?
My name is Dokey Bird.
Today we're going to be playing Happy Wheels.
All right.
Let's see.
You know what?
What's this?
through as fast as we can because we are.
Let's get the original three levels.
Going back, you're right.
It is 2012.
Guys, we survived 2012.
Original level three.
Let's go kill the guy who put you in that thing.
I don't care.
But dad.
Oh, shit.
Where are the controls?
Oh, that did.
Oh, down to my son.
Give me a soul.
good that's oh yeah kony 2012 that was you know that was a
scam the entire the guy went the guy who did that by the way
um oh oh no i fucked up again oh no my son guys guys um um
Oh, okay, wait.
Oh, God.
Riding a bike is actually a lot harder than you guys think.
Guys.
No!
My family!
Oh, my ass.
Oh, no.
I'm trying to just have one leg.
Oh, and I'm riding backwards.
I'm...
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
It's fine.
Every...
We made it!
Let's go!
Don't worry, my dog.
We came so far.
All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
All right.
Surely the car's not coming.
All right, all right.
Gamers don't look back.
Oh, guys, always wear your helmets.
And always, always wear your helmets.
I'm down!
Okay, as long as I live.
Ah!
I bore...
Helmet actually worked as long as...
Alright, let's just watch this murder happen in front of us.
Alright.
What a lovely day to ride my bike.
Wait, then who died?
Oh!
Well, I mean...
That answers the...
Oh, fuck.
And me too.
That answers my question.
Oh, my God.
Wait, guys.
This game is...
This game might be...
Might be a little high.
That's all right.
Surely...
See, wear your helmets, guys.
No, we just need you to play Gmod Cry of Fear and Amnesia
for Peak Choice.
Oh, the thing is, I...
No!
No, I got distracted!
Oh, no!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's the little one.
No, okay, slow it, steady, slow it.
Just a little, it's okay.
Just a little poke.
It's like it's like that massage acupuncture just somehow
Okay, maybe we fucked up on the acupuncture Maybe You fell
for it again.
Sorcerer, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The thing is, Sorcerer, I've actually played two out of
three of those games on stream before.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
um i don't know if i'll play amnesia though not i'm neat i
don't i just don't like resources horror management type
deal wear your helmet kids helmet is important all right
here we go there's no way i can fuck this up no it's all
right i didn't want to pay for oh shit okay no never mind
when it hits the when it hits the head that's guys i don't
know you guys know that but like um
potentially die for those who didn't know uh not that though
because i wore a helmet okay all right let's i need the
momentum uh i need them okay wait wait no way yeah spike
through your head may or may not cause instant death oh okay
all right okay it's fine no no it's okay i'll I'll...
No!
It's okay.
Just a...
There we go.
See?
A player from Happy Reels, bro.
That game is dead.
All right.
I'm tired.
Don't, don't, don't.
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
It's five.
We're...
We're Tohoing.
Hobo Toho.
Don't know you're dead.
I'm not looking.
I don't care anyway.
How many?
Oh, stop.
Oh, that's a good question.
I think it was for a bottle run.
I did it.
Seventy sword.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, I did do it.
I did do it.
So yeah, I figured it out.
Guys, I figured out how to do this.
I just gotta make sure I don't get hit by that.
Oh, it's all right.
I love yo-yos.
go well we're technically alive i had the hell with it for
me well at least my child oh my gosh at least my child's
alive guys how is this is three levels this is level one how
okay all right Oh my god!
When...
I guess the...
Okay, the Let's Players made this game look so easy.
How do they make it sound?
You know, when you're a kid, you're like, oh my gosh, how do
they keep fucking up?
I can do this.
I...
I died to death.
This is, that would be like, I'd be like, oh my gosh, so
see, I, I can do this.
It's like, yeah, oh, you're right, I'm missing the editing,
editing magic.
I forgot, they get to edit, edit the tries out, the failures
out.
So it looks like I did it first try, first try, oh, shit,
oh, no.
Oh my god, I forgot to get the perfect run.
I need to do this 800 times.
Oh my god, not again Not again.
Not again Here I need the free YouTube music Zero does first
try guys right here.
Oh, well first drive right now.
Oh fuck don't worry first try us Hey guys, it's my first
time playing happy wheels.
So we're gonna do this first try.
Oh god.
Oh god How did my child get here?
How did my wheelies?
okay oh oh there you go i gotta sacrifice the child will
understand she said he sacrificed himself for for his mom
it'll be fine no college let's go all right oh no oh no okay
okay i was gonna say how will i get back on my bike all
right exactly we didn't need that child wait don't know that
glitched oh really okay there you go all right four bottom
run all right how do i do this effectively do i a wrap i'll
wrap it up
every time okay i think i have to i have to do a wheelie
maybe maybe it's time for the wheelie Oh, God, it's okay.
I don't need arms to ride a bike.
What I learned is you don't need...
Oh, God.
You don't need arms.
This is an armless bike.
Okay.
I gotta do a wheelie.
Oh, oh, oh, gosh.
My...
Oh, my...
All right.
Oh, my leg!
Uh...
All right, here we go.
You're part of the ready-setty go cover was really many they
give a super chat.
Oh the men released it Was that got that got released
Really really time oh we made it we made it my beautiful kid
and I oh you really expect the core level they don't exist
No, no, no, no, no Oh, oh, there you are elevator
Just as planned wait, what's going on here, too?
Wait, is this it?
Are we done?
All right.
Call it back down.
How do I get?
Oh, no.
I fell off the elevator.
No.
We were so...
Backflip.
Yeah, originally.
I don't...
Originally, I was supposed to be released for her birthday,
I think.
I remember.
So I'm glad it's finally out.
I actually don't remember what part I sang there.
It's been a while.
I've recorded that song a while ago.
So I actually don't remember.
Oh, all right.
It's going to be...
Let's see.
We can reset this.
There we go.
We reset it.
Yeah.
It was recorded a couple of months ago From what I remember
Oh my, okay, now I don't think I can recover
Now I don't think I can recover from that I'm glad it's
finally out I know that there was like a lot of us being a
part of it too Oh my god, it's been 20 minutes And I'm still
in level 1
Where's my movie editing magic?
Oh, I'll be fine.
I'll be fine.
I'll no no sacrifice my kid Okay, she was dead weight
anyway.
We didn't need the extra weight there you go No edits to be
fat.
Oh god, where's my where's my YouTube edit magic?
Little Timmy goodbye little Timmy.
Don't worry mommy will have Timmy number two There you go
four Okay, that's what I can do now Really, really no, I'm
so There was no there's no brakes on this bike
There's no break how did they do this Where are the brakes
okay there you go I Almost felt so safe oh no it's okay it's
okay he was my meat shield no oh god no it's okay it's okay
it's okay acupuncture is is healthy for you these are these
it's like massage these are massage modes oh my god that wow
that felt so good guys oh i feel so relaxed now all right so
all right timmy was our was our shield this was our
bulletproof vest all right duck thank you the super chat
thank you thank you thank you uh while you were stuck on
this level i downloaded the game and opened the level and
beat on my first try gg easy duck thank you super chat thank
you thank you oh yeah i bet you had youtube magic there
patria said you was super chat thank you thank you speaking
of 2012 did you know the last time new dimension was added
to my card was in roughly 2012 anyone who they just
announced the wait really what dimension did they announce
baturasu thank you with super chat thank you thank you gg
easy cover when you see if it wasn't like oh no oh oh oh if
it wasn't like an ai song i would love to do a cover of it
why are you still appearing in my life why is happy will
still appear in my life the ether what do you have in the
ether let's go back to 2016 then go back boom oh Doritos oh
my god he altered all right oh that's my husband I think
I've also been locking a cage I yeah what do you mean the
future oh this is perfect oh my god Thank you, Shia LaBeouf.
All right.
What else am I supposed to do?
Hello?
Oh, I'm supposed to break it.
Okay, I'm really scared I'm going to flip at any moment.
I'm really scared.
I'm trying not to...
All right, there you go.
Oh, no.
All right.
All right, we got to get the momentum.
yeah and oh oh that win yeah new world record guys
new world record my record i know i'm so good at video games
guys first try too oh my god Alright, which one should- Oh,
Pokemon Training.
Type my name in Search and Visit My Other Levels, too.
What's this?
Pokemon Training.
Oh, let's get the Vespa guy.
I choose you.
That's me.
Pokemon Gym.
Alright.
Oh, Pikachu!
How do I kill him?
Oh, shit!
Well, I guess it's the...
Sorry, Segway.
What the fuck is a Vespa?
What?
the fuck i'm like what is the wait what is the best but what
the fuck
um all right there you go in my segue oh oh hey my chop all
right let me give me a sec you it's a little bit dirty
around here uh you gotta clean up bro Oh, jigglypuff.
Okay, how is that going to kill me?
Jigglypuff is coming.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, my God, she's here.
Self-destruct?
Oh, I mean, I guess I can just...
Oh, hello, lady.
Are you having a great time?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
All right.
Oh, I can jump with the segue.
I remember when the media was trying so hard to make the
segue work.
but like i feel like nope like i feel like no one at like
the only times you've ever seen it segways is like on tv i
swear i've never seen anyone publicly use a segway oh no not
the bear oh no the original the original pdf files
I'm gonna be the very best like no one ever was Dream them
is my Pokemon Yay
The original PDF file
Easy First try Alright actual first try Just like every
other time I played a level Alright let me I'm gonna pick
him up Yeah I'm gonna pick him up I'm gonna pick him up
all right i did not pick him up guys i unfortunately oh guys
i think this one's appropriate oh it's the biker dad come on
son today we're gonna go on a wonderful trip at the bridge
Don't you know Do not get it on front flip Oh no worries I
prosthetics are a thing No dad don't you I'm sorry I can't
do it I can't do it without cringing Look at that Jordan
don't guys Just oh I mean I think we're supposed to go down
here Around that time guys It wasn't considered cringe Oh
goodbye Son, never loved you anyway.
Calm down.
Little Timmy.
It's a dokey, but it's still funny today.
Oh, that's fine.
It's fine.
Why else do you think I brought my son here?
See, son, your father is in a lot of debt.
And I may or may not.
have taken life insurance for one of us.
May or may or may not.
All right, don't worry.
It's all about the speed.
Whoooooo!
That's right.
We gotta keep going, son.
Daddy doesn't want to get his legs broken.
But fine, I don't think it's any of that to yourself.
Speed is key.
Look at that.
Easy.
See, guys, I don't know why you guys didn't want me to go on
the bridge.
It seemed really fun.
Chat.
Tech in three.
I put everything I know about Happy Wheels.
You hear that, Matt?
Oh, yeah, someone just talked about it.
Also, sadly, because I was sick, I was not able to afford.
No!
I hope you're maybe in the future.
um chat think of a super chat thank you thank you um but
what is in the new minecraft realm what even is in it oh bye
son oh taken three i i thought that's it i was like oh shake
out way to play taken what did that say give me a sec no no
no bring me back bring bring me back to what did that say
that's uh oh Oh, hey, guys, look, you didn't need a double
tap.
Like, one is okay.
Timmy will not be returning for Taken 3.
Mississauga McClarkly Coltskin.
Oh, wow, how did I break my arm?
You'll have to bypass the sneaky...
Oh, okay.
No, okay.
Okay.
All right, let's see.
Yeah, but can a blade stop?
Ah!
Um, the blade can stop.
When you're one day from retirement.
So apparently it could.
Alright, here we go.
Apparently, yes.
Alright, don't worry.
I'll block.
I'm gonna use...
I'm gonna right-click my block.
And the blade stops.
that's like oh shit okay yeah that's right that's right I
activated my defense card oh shit okay all right backflip
all right but did she expect the third guy a large gun wait
and take the lift to the roof okay I mean oh all right nice
it's a little the little rooftop What is he gonna do?
Shoot me?
Oh!
What the...
Russia!
His... Oh!
There you go.
I did it.
What is he...
What else is he gonna do?
Oh, is that it?
Does he only have one bullet?
Oh, I guess he only has one bullet.
Alright, goodbye, bro.
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
He's best friends with a certain guy who owns an island.
We didn't know that back then.
We didn't know about that.
Mal, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Doki.
Just got raised.
I also found out.
Oh, congratulations.
Malak.
Thank you for the super.
Oh.
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Oh, okay.
Well, clearly not there.
Oh, God.
Okay.
It's just a child.
All right.
Alright, we don't have to worry about that.
Alright.
Congratulations!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Congrats on the on the promotion!
More responsibilities!
Yippee!
But then it's worth it.
More disposable income.
I think that's the best part.
Of being adult.
Alright.
Okay, that's just sad, bro.
Come on, get out of here.
Oh shit!
Okay, that's alright, there you go.
expect the third guy oh guys never get acupuncture for the
brain I don't think it's as effective that's for the breast
of the body all right it's fine it's fine first try take one
you didn't expect the third guy I am I made of bones and
like am I made of paper how the fuck did I oh it's okay it's
all right oh activate blocking i paid five dollars to block
all right that's just sad bro all right let's oh my god let
me wheelie this out of here no oh no oh congratulations on
your new oh no i no
okay i accidentally ejected myself off the bike like what
has the sun done for me though honestly like what do i get
out of this i can make a new sun i could get grab one
they're like practically free at them they're like
practically free at the okay guys i'm already dead okay this
is actually overkill yeah but you can grab them for free at
the orphan okay maybe Sorry, I'm sorry.
This is 2012, Doki.
I'm a little more edgier.
If I was the content creator in 2012.
Guys, I'm just role playing, guys.
I'm just...
Guys, back in 2012, everyone was a little edgier back then.
That's fucked up.
User, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
are made of toothpicks, paper, minus shade, and tomato, holy
shit, he fucking projectile me there.
Alright, okay, now I have to make sure I don't get stabbed
in the ass from these.
He, like, threw me so far up.
Alright.
Alright, let me get the...
Oh.
Alright.
Okay, and then we gotta kill it.
Oh!
No!
Back in 2012, bikes had no bricks guys we just didn't know
better the only protection we needed was the helmet that's
all we had oh god it's fine it's fine first try take one
first time on this level chat oh okay oh you know what let's
take him on for a ride i'm still alive at this point oh
please oh congratulations on your penis extension surgery
it's been a success okay oh it's all right let me figure
this out just a flesh wound all right did it oh no no don't
take me back all right nice there we go we did it we made it
not even oh don't see guys look at that not even that hard i
got the splinter out of my body didn't feel a thing okay
okay break break rewind time well it doesn't really matter i
just need to get out of it okay i get i guess it does matter
All right, now I can leave.
No, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, okay.
Oh, my God.
No, no, no, do not present yourself.
All right.
Nice.
It's okay.
We're not the target here.
We're not the target audience for this guy.
Okay.
The leap of faith.
Oh.
No!
Let me in!
Please, I am the son.
I got to be the star that took me on the ride, but I thought
I was.
Well.
All right.
We can do this.
I mean, I just got to believe.
I didn't believe hard enough.
That was my problem.
All right.
Get blocked.
That's right.
Swiped.
Oh, my God.
No!
That's a team.
That's illegal.
Wait, you have to dismount the bike?
There's...
Guys, how do I dismount?
Okay, let's press all the buttons I know.
And, guys, it's enter.
I figured it out.
Okay.
Alright, we know how to dismount the bike.
That's what he meant by leap of faith, guys.
The double team.
um that was a 1v2 uh that was illegal this was supposed
where is the honor all right here you go all right there you
go there's no way you can there's no way you can oh oh okay
all right guys just a normal saturday afternoon it's just oh
there you go just a splinter I didn't feel a thing.
Barely felt anything.
Oh, there was something on me?
Alright.
Let's see.
No!
Okay, wait, I can still ride my bike.
I...
But I...
But I wore a helmet!
How is this pop?
What's the point I'm wearing a helmet if it can't protect me
from decapitation?
Guys, see, helmets don't work.
It's like toilet paper.
It's like when the toilet paper company tries to get...
Oh, shit!
Doki, wait, what do you mean, Doki?
I meant toilet paper company tries to convince you not to
buy a bidet.
So you would always buy more toilet paper.
Bidets are objectively better.
reason it's not normalized in N.A.
Every time I come back to N.A.
I feel like a caveman using toilet paper.
Yeah, toilet paper is a scam from Big Toilet.
But days are the future.
Get with the times, N.A.
Get on with the times.
Big toilet paper has a hold over N.A.
But we all nope but days are the future we're going
backwards not forwards
just like helmets what's the point of wearing helmets if it
doesn't protect you from decapitation exactly what's the
point of wearing a helmet can't protect me from an axe
big toilet's gonna catch you All right, here we go.
They sell bidets that you can install in your toilet from
wall.
I got distracted from a big toilet.
Conspirator.
Gordon, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
It's not the same, Gordon.
It's you know it.
It's not the same.
Oh, God.
All right.
Big toilet strikes again.
Don't be sheepa.
Think for yourself.
Don't let them think for you.
Ah!
Alright.
Oh my god.
How many attempts have I gone on this game?
JK, it still is attempt number one.
Don't worry.
The YouTube magic.
We'll get the YouTube magic on this.
It wouldn't be funny if I just edited out all my other
attempts in this video.
The stream becomes like 30 minutes.
I private the stream and every attempt, make it all first
try.
Put the live, what live chat?
It's a let's play video.
There will only be three levels on the stream.
It'll be a 20 minute vibe What do you mean?
This is a let's play video.
There's no chat.
It's just comments.
Make sure to hit the notification bell button And subscribe
All right, first first try
Guys, don't worry first try Yeah, this is a happy wheels
funny moments montage All right, there you go.
Oh no, I don't go go Oh, it's okay.
It's all right.
Okay.
No, get back on the bike.
Get back on the bike.
I accidentally checked it.
And stay tuned for the next one.
Bye-bye, brofist.
I celebrated a little too early.
I prematureed celebrated there.
The fact, I got through the first level and I was okay.
How?
Ever since... Ever since...
I learned how to eject, I've never got past the first level.
Ever since I learned how to eject myself, I've been stuck in
this purgatory.
They've adapted in the new happy wheels.
They added AI learning to the NPCs for the steam, just for
the steam release okay that must be done oh god oh god oh
thank god i was gonna say he takes me back to the axe man i
swear to god i'm so ahead of its time okay come on come on
do something oh god okay all right as long as i don't get my
head blown up it should be fine oh oh god okay
all right we made it oh oh oh no no my helmet what would i
do oh god oh god all right here you go okay all right i
don't need no arm for this i just need to get up here what a
parrot bicycle foo
get up
grab i can grab all right all right guys yes yes we might
guys i guys i need i need a place i can't i can't i first
stop let me learn how to grab first stop all right lean oh
my god there's this is a controller okay keyboard control
all right eject is z what happened Why did XM get good?
Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Second, there's a secondary action.
Secondary shift control.
Where the fuck did Enter come from?
Well, Enter did something.
I just don't know what it did.
Oh, there's so many fucking levels.
Oh, Temple Run.
I should love Temple Run.
Oh my God, it actually is.
Oh my god, it actually is Temple Run!
He'll take me to...
Wait, he can take me to the end.
Okay.
Alright, that's dismounting.
Oh, hey.
Wait, that's my ride.
Okay.
Wait, Temple Run's so easy.
Oh.
Um...
Oh...
all right hey guys tempo runs so easy do i need all the
coins i don't think so an original tempo run is not that it
was i mean it was still you don't need all the coins do you
need time oh my god oh my god what's the point of having
momentum if i can't use it
okay no no all right maybe it'll take me to the end all
right i i want to see where will take me.
He'll he'll win the game for me, guys.
Let's go.
This mode is so easy.
Look at that.
I did it.
We did it, guys.
We made it to the end.
Oh god.
Oh god, please.
He's right behind me.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Alright, nice.
Jump.
Yay!
First try.
Don of the dead.
Let's go all the way up.
User level browser.
Oh!
Wait, you can...
You can make... Oh my god, that's so cool!
All right, play count.
Uh, any time.
Uh, play count.
Where's, like, the most played?
Please, please sort it out by most played, please.
Browse by, by, oh, wait, no, not by date.
Oh, that's so cool.
Oh, my God, they have, like, the OG levels, too.
Like, the OG, uh, like, uh, user-made levels right here.
Oh, there's a refresh button.
I just saw that.
Okay, how about this week?
Alright, the day before Steam.
For Happy Wheels, nothing but me personally, I think it's
quite a while.
And while Happy Wheels is the only day away from getting...
So I thought it was worth making.
Oh, that's so cute.
Alright.
Happy Wheels is only two days away from release.
Not exactly.
It's just Happy Wheels Steam release.
Man, these years flew by.
So many good YouTube memories of this game.
like the game is dying it's just getting don't you realize
that we're old where are the other characters though they're
only five of us six including your son i believe it'll come
around a second before the win oh happy wheels happy happy
wheels release day yippee um season thank you for that super
chat thank you thank you What do you do?
What do you mean?
I completed my quick time.
My quick time.
Guys, we passed the bridge.
I completed my quick time event.
We did it, guys.
All right, what about wrestling ball, throw, extended
version to test out happy wheels on steam?
How do I do this?
Okay.
grab, grab, grab, which button is grab, grab, grab, grab,
grab, grab, grab, grab, guys, my, oh, that was scary, oh,
my God, oh, my God, my entire monitor blanked out there,
okay, I grabbed a little too high, I, I may or may not have
grabbed a little too hard.
Yeah, I thought I crashed there.
I was like, and then all my monitors blanked out.
And I was just like, what happened?
All right, let me reboot this real quick.
No!
I have to set everything up again.
All right, give me a sec.
I need to reset.
I need to set this up again.
I crashed, guys.
Sorry, my thing crashed.
Or is it?
Or maybe my PC's died.
It could be either, honestly.
I could never tell.
I walked away.
I gotta go get water real quick.
See, we're being immersive.
It's chair time.
We're just being immersive, guys.
It's just immersion.
Oh, my gosh.
I need to find my headphones again.
Where's the headset?
Oh, oh, that's not what I wanted.
Oh, oh.
Wait, where am I?
I whooped myself away.
Oh.
Where did I go?
There I am.
I think I was, like, right here?
There we go.
Close enough.
Good enough.
All right.
We're back.
We're back, guys.
It's no more chair time.
It's just like...
Okay.
All right.
Grab.
Okay.
Oh.
Grab!
Oh, no, no, no, not death!
It's really nothing bad.
Wait, wait a minute.
Oh, death is here.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
All right.
Okay.
Oh.
Help?
Come on.
You can do this.
You used to be a...
wait she's oh okay she seems okay there you go lose one ball
no my ball oh nothing okay come on that's legal oh no nine
balls drop all balls oh hey nope nope oh okay it's fine
nothing no they gave me oh no no It's okay.
I'll just start twerking.
It's a Alright Okay I lost 50 limbs Where?
I still have it all!
Oh come on Come on just grab it My arms are too short Oh
there you go Okay what?
Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh I did it.
Man, I wish I had a ball to throw that.
Pull the strategy.
Oh, I wish.
If only I had one more ball.
Okay.
All right, we got help.
Oh, thank God.
Another one.
That thing.
Thank God.
I...
All right, another one.
unlock proof there we go oh that's fine all right oh it's
okay death was blocked come on oh come on daddy's got this
don't worry don't worry daddy has long arms three extra bars
let's go three extra bars just to miss let's go I didn't
think that would add I would actually miss all right
whatever
ah don't worry I have another bot I have another bot okay
what do you think nothing means guys surely nothing doesn't
mean nothing there we go three extra balls all right
Oh, come on!
No!
Oh, wait.
What does that do?
Oh!
Hey, I found my daughter, though.
All right.
It's fine.
Three extra balls.
Come on.
It's fine.
One less ball.
Oh, come on!
What's all nice?
Three extra balls.
Infinite money glitch.
Oh, no, no.
Get her away from me.
No!
Don't grab me!
I jump!
That's right.
I game the system.
If I... I never died.
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'm still here.
Oh, don't worry.
It's like I never died.
So you've chosen death.
Maybe I'll... Oh, wait.
I can do this.
Wait, okay, now I can, okay, oh, wait, oh, that's not good,
oh, no, no, no, no, she's coming for, oh, don't, go on my
ass, it's okay, it's okay, it's so loud, I'm, I barely, I
don't feel a thing at all, sweetie, don't worry, never run
with your, oh, never run with your katanas, guys, accident
you'll get it okay I can win this where did my ball go where
did it go where did the ball go oh why is there so many
deaths why is it all why is it just all deaths oh come on
all right nice one less death nice two okay still still
doesn't really help me but oh no not the kid all the kids
gonna come here okay oh just absolute nothing oh no no not
her not her okay where does it close there's still one more
death though all right win oh oh no not all the balls No!
Don't let her near me.
No!
One last try.
No, I lost my ball.
Oh, hey.
Nice.
Alright.
Nothing.
I did it.
I...
It's fine.
Oh, come on.
Oh, don't get scared.
We got help.
Oh, grab it.
Grab it.
are so short.
Duh!
No.
Physics is so hard.
Any physics professor here?
Can anyone calculate the momentum I need to... Oh, no, not
all the balls.
No.
I keep forgetting I have to do it this all.
It's okay.
I still have one more.
Something about this is so...
What are you talking about?
I'm trying.
I swear to God.
Someone, please.
What's the math for the velocity and the angle?
Someone calculate the angle.
Oh my God.
I don't need all help.
I'm just trying to unlock Provisional Wind.
Please.
Someone unlock it.
Now get her away from me now hey another help all right okay
no just oh goodbye pi square minus the root of infinity okay
but like do you account for the win factors though oh my god
oh my god this might be but i'm so good at throwing oh no no
no i just unlocked I just unlocked it!
The one time I unlocked it.
No!
No, no, not first try.
Where did it go?
The instant throw.
Okay.
me out of this level oh my god accidentally screenshot this
game give me a give me give me i can't i can't i can't
anymore all right what's the combine this is a version so i
might update it oh my gosh that's a lot of playthrough oh
what where am i did i win did i oh my god Oh, shit.
Oh, my end.
Uh, Dick, thank you for the alka-supa.
Thank you, thank you.
There's not too much to ask.
It's, uh, my birthday.
It was my birthday a couple of days ago.
It would be okay, my kami.
I'm sure you could wish me out.
Of course!
Happy birthday!
When my heart went mad as you do for us, and friends, we
couldn't ask for anyone better cheer for thank you, the
alka-supa!
And happy belated birthday!
Dick, happy birthday!
Happy belated!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Dick Bucket, 69.
That's a great name, by the way.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the alcoa soup, buddy.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
All right.
Okay, now that I know that there is a thing that would kill
me, as per all the levels, I don't know why I haven't
learned that yet.
I know, and I now know what to do.
All right.
Who would have thought?
Every level kills you.
Oh.
Ah!
Okay.
I can outrun this.
As we all know.
Oh, fuck.
It's okay.
I can outrun this.
A piece of my body.
Whoa.
Oh.
Don't worry.
As we all know.
A long mower machine.
Oh.
Hey.
Good for me, at least.
Hey, look at that.
I made it.
Yippee!
We did it!
We...
Oh!
In the end, at least a part of me.
A part of me made it to the finish line.
And that's all that matters.
Polo Venture.
Okay.
We got this.
That is crouch.
Okay.
Alright.
It's Pogo time.
We can do this.
Slowly but surely.
First try, no damage.
What are that?
We're on a little adventure, everybody.
D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-Dora.
D-Dora.
Dora-Dora-Dora-Dora, Dora.
Dora-Dora-Dora.
Dora-Dora-Dora-Dora.
Grab your friends.
Bada.
Bada-Dom.
Alright.
Wait.
Is it?
Was Pogo Man voiced by Uber Hacks or Nova?
I actually did not...
That actually makes a lot more sense now to me.
Because he was always playing the Pogo Man.
I did not realize that that was him.
I didn't...
I didn't know.
There was...
Oh!
Oh.
Well...
Were there any other YouTubers that voiced characters?
I don't put BGM.
Alright, let's put BGM.
Or some... Do I have any BGM on here?
okay that's a good question actually let me see what's the
way was this one i actually don't know what bgm this one is
so i'm always worried about putting something random in here
uh where the is it what bgm is this oh oh no it's gonna get
copyright shrank if i use this do i have any bgm that i can
put on here that is a Good question.
Let's see.
Oh, I do.
What's this?
What BGM is this?
All it's called is...
Okay, here we go.
I have this.
Yay!
Come on.
Come on, come on.
You got this.
Pogo man.
You got this Pogo man.
Front flip.
Oh, my God.
I got a achievement.
front flip back flip every flip can be a front flip if you
dream hard enough the power of helmets there is it's just
very quiet I think I fell into a time loop oh it's okay you
don't need arms for Pogo for Pogo man Ellie thank you super
chat thank you thank you OG Doki stealing my wallet and my
heart dr cranberry think of a super chat thank you thank you
ah yes i like to call this move the tumbleweed oh come on
you got this all right it's fine run flip gotta do some
trick shots here gotta do some trick shots for for the
stream whoa it'll be too easy all right got this oh Oh god,
okay, I don't know if it was a stalagmite or stalactite.
Eh.
I was born extra.
I was born made of...
Made of slime.
Look at that.
My bones are noodles.
Ah, yes.
Like, ah, Pogo Adventures.
You just tumble.
It just works, guys.
Hey, if it works, it works.
Ha ha ha.
We did it.
And that's how you pogo, guys.
Yeah, I'm a pogo expert.
This man is a slinky.
What's the office?
This is my newest level of the office with many details.
Was this actually?
Oh, I thought it was like the office these show.
Oh my god, this guy actually made a fucking keyboard in
this.
in happy wheels that's oh god oh god okay posted all right
son let's take your son to work day but they didn't say take
your son home though see it's called take your son to work
day not take your son home after work day oh god damn it
that's it get son wait what if i do the pogo strat
unless I don't need a bike.
Wait, I don't think I need a bike.
Wait, we got...
Okay.
I can do this.
The worm.
I don't think I need a bike.
There you go.
Slow and steady.
Oh, I figured it out.
I got the rhythm.
I...
No!
I said myself.
Wait.
This is okay.
I got the rhythm going in.
I don't need no bike.
No.
Don't.
Not backwards.
Oh, wait.
If I flip myself backwards, I might be able to use that
momentum.
Here.
All right.
Oh, how do you break your fucking... Oh, my God.
Wait.
My son.
We're connected telepathically.
We're... Oh, my God.
This is it.
Okay.
This is the plan.
My son and I.
It's like we're piloting a mech together.
Here we go.
Okay.
If we learn anything, we can propel ourselves like this.
There we go.
And then...
Oh no.
Not a fucking gap.
My one weakness!
A hole!
Not the hole.
There we go.
We're drifting together.
Alright.
It's fine.
We're almost there.
We're at pencil level.
I thought Pokemon taught me how to pilot my body better.
Oh my god, son!
Son, bring the bike over, son!
Son!
My only weakness, a ledge.
No.
I thought we could do this, son.
I really did.
I believe it's so hard, boy.
I really believe.
Maybe my son will live on.
Continue with my legacy.
Oh, he's useless.
I told my wife it's weird that he didn't learn to speak
after he turned three.
It's been three years, and he still doesn't know how to
speak.
I knew something was up, let alone the fact that he can't
walk, but like...
Hey, Toki, so...
Oh, hey, that's a rat.
What is he gonna do?
Look at that.
See?
Nothing.
Fucking weak.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
It'll be fine.
See, I've always believed.
So, could I see you playing this classic game?
My birthday was on the 24th.
Can I get a happy birthday too?
Of course!
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
A happy birthday.
And it was your birthday.
And I beat a level.
I might as well be my birthday.
Baron, thank you.
The Super Chat.
Thank you.
See you.
Happy birthday to you.
birthday dear bear happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday
we had a great birthday for Abby thank you for super chat
thank you thank you dude one of my favorite happy wheel
levels is chaos city I definitely recommend giving that
level a shot glad you see you play the game thank you super
chat thank you thank you it's my first time playing it too
uh I've always watched stream streamers play but I've never
played it myself all right chaos is this one chaos city core
god 42 million plays all right kirby ponich okay wait i
never seen the indiana jones oh wait we gotta be santa yep
yep come on come on christmas is coming we got it oh it's
fine oh it might not be fine i don't pay you in gumdrops to
be slow see this is a great thing about employing elves
they're not unionized okay we might have to we might have to
change characters oh wait let's see what did let's watch the
replay watch the mod what did i do wrong jump boys jump that
joke i was i didn't learn to speak until i was five or six
kanga thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh i
can fly i can fly it's a christmas miracle oh i can still
fly No!
If there's too much weight, we gotta get rid of one of the
elves.
Not me, though.
Santa don't need...
Oh, Zenpig.
Okay.
It's fine.
Santa's coming.
You better watch out.
You better...
Oh, we actually might have to lose one of you.
Well, I said...
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, guys, we might be a little too thick.
Oh, no.
better watch out you better not cry about not because i'm
telling you why santa claus now an ostrich is coming to town
he knows when you've been asleep it's okay santa's still
ready to santa's still ready all right nice santa's still
here all right guys let's show oh my god where does where
should santa go where do santa go don't worry santa's still
here santa still has christmas magic we can always replace
the great thing about elves is that we have an elf problem
so oh it wasn't that way he was learning to tie a knot all
right don't worry we have the ostrich momentum
all right there you go come on come on those we'll do your
thing all right Santa's gotta Santa's got a lot of
deliveries to do Santa's doing it early come on those yep
yep yep yep don't you want to see your family kids come on
guys oh my god I'm running out of Christmas magic guys No!
But I want to be Santa!
Oh, I cannot be... Alright, we'll just be him.
Surely we can beat this level with this guy.
Surely.
Guys, it's not cheating.
They gave me this character.
Oh, God.
Oh, thank God.
Alright, how do I... Oh, it's okay.
He's fine.
Oh, how do I drive this?
Oh, don't worry.
I just got my license.
It's unrelated to whatever the fuck I'm piloting, but I have
a license somewhere.
I...
Oh my god, how do I go for it?
How do I go for it?
Oh, the goddamn team!
No!
Come on!
Alright, we broke the table.
Now we have...
Oh god.
Oh, wait, this is where I have to go.
Okay, I have to go that way.
Alright, and then I'll go...
Oh, wait.
I can break that.
Wait.
From what I learned in Pogo, man.
It's okay.
That was just unneeded weight anyway.
From what I learned in Pogo, man.
This is still possible.
Oh, whoa, man.
Whoa.
Guys, guys, this is what it looks like.
Guys, I swear to God, this isn't what it looks like.
Guys, I swear to God.
Oh my god, I need to get rid of this dead fucking weight off
my fucking bike.
Is this a louder?
What do you mean?
What do you mean, guys?
I'm just...
That poor lady, she lost her shoe.
I'm trying to find it.
I'm just trying to find this poor lady.
Look at, guys.
I found her shoe, guys.
Oh, God.
Oh, duh.
Alright.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
We got the momentum.
It's okay.
Oh, no, not my legs.
We got the momentum.
We did it.
We're almost there.
Oh!
Oh, you're so close.
Alright, someone said I need a...
Alright, it's fine.
I know how to pilot this now.
I figured it out.
Alright, and then we have to...
So, we have to go this way anyway.
And then...
Go through the bathroom.
And then go up.
Go up!
Alright.
Pass the first hurdle.
Oh, this is the easiest level of my life.
Surely I can fly past this.
Wow, this level is pretty easy.
Your ass is mine.
You think she's okay?
You think her ass is okay?
Oh, see, look at that.
She's fine.
What is this there?
Oh my god, a UFO.
Oh my god, he got abducted.
He's gonna get probed.
Oh, little Timmy is fine.
A little bit of upper body surgery.
We'll fix it.
Oh my god, what's going on?
What's going on in the city?
King Kong!
Zombies!
Santa?
But it's a...
Oh, well, Godzilla, Mothra?
I mean, well, the guy didn't die from zombies, at least.
I saved the day.
Oh, oh.
Oh, God.
It's okay.
I still have brains.
This is Sparta.
Oh, my God.
Batman!
What city are we in?
We did.
Oh, that...
You know what?
They were right.
It was Chaos, the ultimate showdown.
Yes.
This city had everything.
Hey, no.
No.
No bark.
What in the city of 2012?
Alright.
We got Chaos City done.
I want to try Happy Green Hills.
What do we have for Happy Green Wheels?
Alright, let's do...
Wheelchair Men.
Oh, wait.
I have a rocket here.
Oh, yeah.
I assume this is Sonic, right?
Oh, no.
I'm going backwards.
Not again.
Go, go, wheelchair, go, live on for me.
Live on.
Guys, soon this is based off of Sonic.
Oh, no, not against.
Okay, my wheelchair.
My wheelchair is still going.
It's still on.
I'm still on it.
Guys, I play.
might be over.
I can rotate the rocket.
Oh, God, this is so hard to control.
Okay.
Oh, I thought putting a rocket on a wheelchair might not
have been the brightest of ideas.
Oh, I thought, oh, 20 front flips, though.
Oh, no, this is so hard.
To the moon.
Just take me to the moon.
I don't think this a rocket wheelchair.
I don't think he has the credentials for this.
What kind of sick fuck gave this man a rocket?
Yeah, this might be it might not.
Yeah, Indiana Jones.
Oh, what the fuck?
How can I fuck it up?
I fucked it up.
I...
There's no way I can fuck up Santa.
Ho, ho, ho.
Alright, my little elves.
These are the elves I wanted to unionize.
So I decided to give them an even better job.
If they weren't happy, maybe they shouldn't have tried to
unionize.
Oh, that's okay.
One guy's still alive.
Oh, well, I'm still alive.
Oh, God.
Where am I?
I don't remember this in Sonic.
I...
I don't remember this.
How do I go forward?
Alright, nice.
Alright, we gotta wait for this.
Oh, no.
My elves are too heavy.
God damn it, elves.
What happened to all those Zenpik I gave you?
No!
Santa, please!
All right.
Maybe it's time for a segue, man.
It's the elves.
Santa.
Are you trying fat-shame Santa?
Guys?
Look, he needs to be that way to make the sled work.
The calculations and math is all correct.
Oh, I was going to say it's alright.
I still have...
All right.
Oh, nice.
We don't need legs to use a segue.
Oh, come on.
go we're fine we're almost there we're almost there guys
nice nice segue man no it's okay that's not oh that's no
longer okay maybe it's not the pit of despair maybe it'll
lead me to oh okay but it was the furnace we've ever got
it's okay we figured it out segue man is the see hey i hit
those jumps oh god it's okay legs are optional we can always
recon we can rebuild him yeah you can have but imagine how
cool it'll be to have robotic feet huh flesh legs are a
thing of the past old man it's all about the robotic
prosthetic now
We should make this jump.
Oh, God, we don't...
It's okay.
It's not the pit of despair.
Okay.
I'll use the momentum of the segue jump to break...
Okay, look.
It's just because I didn't time it.
Like, if you use the same force to apply, it would, like,
provide, like, no impact.
But, I just mistimed it.
I just...
Yeah, leave the weakness of the flesh.
See, if I had my prosthetic robot legs, I could have tanked
those.
Alright, here we go.
See, I just miscalculated the math.
With no feet, there's no impact.
Alright.
It's fine.
This is just a little elevator.
all right off we go we i'll make those oh i still make those
watch this
um hey uh 50 percent 50 is 50 percent uh well thank you for
this super chat thank you thank you i saw the weirdest thing
to get a guy in a wheelchair guy on a segue and satin went
into caves it didn't come out there oh man they're having a
wild party right now quell and you weren't invited sucks to
be you uh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
nobody's thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
i'm a bit late to stream pretty sick right now i hope you
feel better nobody's uh but wanted to come support and watch
anyway i hope you're doing okay we're able to get plenty of
rest i did i like passed the out i didn't i was not like a
person after the tournament i like dissociated so hard after
the tournament and just like like loafed in my bed until
like today i was actually i was so out of it oh it's a moat
pit i'm near i didn't use this oh it's like based off oh use
space to boost okay all right this tip was not as helpful as
i thought oh come on guys i'm not at this game it's just
it's just because i don't have youtube look i just don't
have youtube magic to edit it all guys i don't think i can
do it i
all right we'll do this level i'm sorry but there's nothing
we can do no my renaissance fair keep out still purple all
right the fact that you like able to make all these like
intricate maps with the the amount of resources they provide
is actually crazy like how the did you make that poster
cross-dimensional vortex all right guys time travel equals
four you see the math is there the math is just right there
i can't believe time travel was just that easy to figure out
it's very innovative for for its time Be able to like
construct all of this with just the amount of resources they
have for them
Oh, we're going back in time Do you know they're rebooting
Doctor Who with who was the actor that they casted for it
Oh, back in the dinosaur time to step on a butterfly Holy
shit, what the fuck Thank God you found me I've been stuck
in the Oh my god, don't worry a rock I'm a second Sarah
Burke for how long that's not gonna happen to me like go
back we gotta go back oh oh shit wait did I okay did I got
tricked by it am I okay my did he take where did he take me
where Oh, see, just enjoying a nice swim with me and my
friends.
Wait, I'm still alive, technically.
I'm still alive.
I'm quadruple...
What is it called?
I'm quadruplee, but I'm still alive.
Yeah, wasn't it Daniel Craig?
Wasn't it Daniel Craig got cast as a new doctor for the
Doctor Who reboot?
Or did I got tricked by...
What was it?
tricked by one of the 200 parody twitter accounts or they
got tricked by disgusting disgusting fish again oh my god i
can't this goddamn microscope
i probably got tricked because i heard they decided to put
doctor who on a hiatus what i remembered um because like the
rate you know the ratings were really low so they're like we
got we got put it on hiatus to reboot it or some shit or
revamp it I got fished god damn it disgusting fish not again
every time every fucking time no I don't think the hiatus is
true they're trying to find a new a new producer that's so
detailed this goddamn dino corpse I've been stuck in this
era for no Johnny will never know how long you've been stuck
in this era for oh it'll be fine I think we can fix we can
rebuild him all right oh my god oh my god oh my god it's
okay that's okay oh it's no longer okay it's so oh it's so
long guys this is just a flesh wound right some people can
live without their heads look at chickens okay maybe I
should not have maybe I should not have crushed the dinos
eggs we have the technology guys in neo prehistoric era we
have the technology oh it's fine I'll get another foot in
dinoland surely I'll find surely I'll find a sign and
Donna's for land to build me a new foot.
Do we have the money?
Inflation hasn't hit yet.
In Neo-prehistoric times.
Thank God.
It's okay.
There's no inflation yet, guys.
Inflation is like...
It's before it's time.
All right.
Get in here.
Oh.
Boy.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
It didn't unlock already.
Alright, nice.
Alright, we don't have to worry about the dinosaur then.
Alright.
Okay, I didn't realize you can go in without activating the
dinosaur.
Thank fucking God.
I don't think I can outrun the dinosaur.
No, there's no way.
There's no way.
Use arms.
Grab here.
Use space.
Land here.
Z.
Okay, give me a sec.
There's like, give me a sec.
There's an instructor.
Oh my god.
My leg!
My fucking bones is cock-blocking me.
Alright, here we go.
There you go.
Land here.
Eject, then immediately hold until you land.
Okay.
Ask first.
Grab here.
Am I dead?
Use arms to grab the Triceratops I don't...
Oh no There we go.
Come on move buddy
We still have the arm I said close enough.
It's close enough.
We did it It said use arm.
I still have one more arm.
I
Thank God.
Thank God We stole that.
God gave us two arms.
Just in case.
My back of arm.
First try.
I legit thought the tail sat me through my heart.
But it's okay.
We made it.
DC Metro Station.
But first you have to take.
Oh.
All right.
What's wrong with the Metro Station?
Boy.
Let's go to the Metro.
true but dad oh well we lost the boy what happened to the
boy i he just he just disappeared how did we lose him that
quickly i walked in and oh my god all right this is a oh no
the metro hey jokie pie when you upload amnesia part four
it's right thank you for this super chat thank you Thank
you.
The metro guy.
This, like, he got it.
He slipped it into the back rooms, guys.
Alright, this is a safety concern.
Why is there a help station in my pathway?
Alright.
Here you go.
Alright, we gotta...
Gotta make sure we don't land on the glass this time.
Alright.
Now we're at the metro.
Oh, shit.
We gotta catch the metro, boy!
be oh well he can catch it i guess we're gonna be late to
school your mom said i can't i can't have you be late again
or you'll get expelled yeah i can't believe this place is
not bicycle friendly guys that's so up it's not bicycle
accessible what are my taxpayers money paying for huh Fun
vault, they give us a super chat thinking, thank you.
We'll do that after this.
I don't think we're going to pass this level, guys.
I have a feeling we might not beat this level.
Unless we're on the metro.
The hard part's over.
Let's hope nothing bad happens at the metro.
That's this.
Drink orange juice.
Thank you, random side.
Oh.
Guys, something bad might have happened at the metro.
like everything happens on guys i think something bad
happened at the metro the boy will live on fun vault thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you ah yes the
average dc metro all right let's try it what is it called
arena of time.
Acure.
Arena of time.
I assume it's the HD one.
Hey, Link.
The great deck who tried summoned you.
It's quite an honor.
Oh, shit.
Yippee.
It really was an honor.
I wonder who was talking back then.
Does he have a knife?
Well, I did not really.
I did not know.
Back in the arena of time, there was a butcher.
the enemies were holding butcher knives thou shalt save one
of which lies inside of myself all right let's go in i feel
so sick oh look if they want me to complete oh yeah oh yeah
that's true this is guys guys are playing um nintendo gave
me early access oh my god nintendo gave me early access to
Ocarina of time.
More like Ocarina of crap.
Yeah, um, unfortunately, things fell hard in the land of
Hyrule.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
On to the cleaver.
Yeah, they fell on hard times, guys.
There's a, there's a, currently a recession in Hyrule right
now.
Unemployment rate went up 80%.
So, and the Princess Zelda decided to increase taxes by 70%.
And unemployment rule, there's a recession right now in
Hyrule.
So things are not the same as you remember the last time you
were here.
One arrow is now 100 rupees.
Exactly.
There's also a war going on, too.
So, time.
Times is rough right now in Hyrule.
The Great Hyrule Depression, guys.
Alright, we made it.
You're having trouble beating.
Then go this way.
Alright, I don't know where that, what that is, but I'm
gonna go this way.
Go.
Go Mina is dead.
Alright, cool.
Cat, don't worry.
We just need your right.
If Cat Adorphe was here, you could fix everything.
Helink, ahead you'll find Death Mountain, home of the Goron.
Slay the beast to reveal the stone of fire.
Well, please let me up here first.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We just gotta get through the first obstacle.
Don't worry, eventually, eventually he'll let me out.
Don't worry, I'm not softlocked.
I just gotta do now with the real boss fight.
No, please, we were so close.
We were so close.
No.
But I beat him.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you gotta...
People can't even afford swords now.
You gotta rent a sword.
Every swing is like another 20 rupees per swing.
Alright.
When you break a pot.
Oh shit.
What the fuck is that?
Is he gonna kill himself?
I did it!
I'm a hero!
See, even he didn't want to live on anymore.
The recession is that bad, guys.
Oh, hey, look, it's the village.
I hope the remake would be fine.
It does not look fine.
The remake doesn't...
Hey, you stop that.
You're ruining my day.
All right, can you leave, sir?
I have a...
I have a princess to save.
What do I...
What do I do?
Oh!
Oh, shit.
Okay, well, they did say Death Mountain.
it i get it i just need to get rid of dead weight he's
definitely dead though the weight's definitely dead we
goodbye to me all right oh sure that's not an explosion
right oh oh all right it's fine okay that's like the weakest
fucking explosion there is like what do you oh okay wait the
doors open.
All right.
Surely that lava's not going to kill him.
Oh.
At first I thought I was immune to lava.
It did look like I was immune to lava for a second.
I don't know.
I thought I'd be different, you know.
Oh.
I guess I wasn't that different.
I forgot the fire tunic.
You're so right.
Ooh, new.
Lava is deadly.
Oh, God.
Bro, come on.
I have a wife, man.
Come on.
Not in front of my kid.
Look, I know time's been tough, bro.
But, bro, not in front of my...
Oh, all right.
Well, you can take my arm.
All right.
again okay nice yay free cleaver all right that's okay we
can ah good we got the body block all right dead weights guy
oh no okay it's fine we don't need arms we don't need arms
guys i bet you link can beat this game without with legs
only oh no no not again no not again the arms added to the
him to the extra weight to get out of this hell!
Body...
What's the point of having kids if you can't use them to
body block?
Huh?
It's like extra shield.
Oh.
Oh, why can't it be like that guy that lived with a pull
through his head?
Alright, nice.
We made it.
Yeah.
That's what meat shield's for.
Oh
Guys, I don't think I can beat this level.
I still have I still had two more bosses the five I
There's still so many levels left
Wait, maybe maybe now that I know now that I know How did I
know how to eject myself and grab on to things?
This is it.
This is it, guys.
I figured it out.
We can do this.
All right.
I'm now a better gamer.
I've upgraded, guys.
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Get parried.
Holy shit.
That's right.
Get momentum.
This is the run.
Here we go.
I have the experience now.
I'm too powerful.
I've leveled up.
You saw me when I was level one.
Look at me now.
Now I'm level six.
Alright, nice.
Just give him a little shimmy.
Oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my god, first try.
Okay.
No!
I was so close.
It was right there.
It just...
I just...
I just needed...
I just needed my arms.
Oh, I can't!
My arms!
Just...
She's just a little bit.
Her only weakness.
I grabbed him.
I was right there.
It was so close.
I saw it.
I saw the light.
There you go.
Get disarmed.
That's fucking right.
Oh, that's fucking right.
Don't worry.
I'll say it.
I'll keep your wife company afterwards.
Don't worry about your wife and kids.
You mean my wife and kids now, buddy.
Alright, oh, look at all these new wives and kids I got.
I played my...
No, no, no.
Oh, my God, I made it back there.
I made it back in time.
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah.
Just gotta take him over there.
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, where's he gonna take me, though?
Maybe he'll take me to the finish line.
Maybe I'll get to see where...
I'll get to see the end.
Hey, where did it go?
Why did he stop the ride?
I was enjoying it.
Why did it give me a face of black?
I'm not his target audience.
I...
I'm not his type, though.
Alright, nice.
Get parried.
I went, surely that's where he's definitely taking me.
Oh, no.
Right in the eye.
No, it kept me.
I just need me level seven, guys.
I was level six.
What's Dawn of the Dead?
level seven oh I that's way too I don't know if I'm if I'm
if I have enough levels for that haunted mansion three three
new monsters oh wait there's lore oh shit shit
faded by lore
they got me guys this guys never this is why you don't read
guys reading is bad it was a trap they got me they fucking
got me they trapped me with lord truly that's uh truly he's
friendly i jump over him can't touch me all right oh this is
awkward um oh this is the weird is this silly all right our
legs got tangled up
Alright.
Here you go.
We can beat one more level.
This game is for kids.
No.
Surely I can beat one more level.
If grown adults can beat this game in 2012.
I'm an adult now.
Okay.
I just got locked in.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I need to use the momentum.
I don't know if the child murder is still behind me.
It's my turn to be an adult.
Just like my, my let's players.
It's very safe here.
I haven't encountered any...
Oh.
See you guys?
Oh, oh my god.
Do not...
Oh.
I'm gonna assume that that is a very bad bad monster.
I'm Yeah, I did it!
See guys, I will do one more level.
We'll do one more.
Don't feel like them.
I gotta carry the torch.
Wait, dead space.
What's this?
Oh my god, it feels just like dead space.
right now please wait what's that is that monster oh don't
okay wait wait wait it's still it's my buddy it's my friend
he's coming around for the ride okay it's okay guys he's
just hanging out with us we're still oh i don't think we got
oh okay come on that's a little overkill it's my new friend
i love my oh i thought that said something else very
accurate all right so the monster's gonna show up right here
all right this time i won't look back this time
oh oh i was gonna say i lived those for like one second I
don't know, what is, I just thought he was friend-shaped,
guys.
He just looked so friend-shaped.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, we're almost there.
No, no, oh god.
Okay, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Oh, nice.
Get dodged.
It's okay.
The momentum will take me over to the finish line.
Ah, I'm down!
Got the momentum!
Betrayed by momentum!
Oh, no!
No!
My segway!
I still have 20 payments left to pay it off!
I...
My momentum!
Go back!
The momentum has been stopped.
Alright.
It's fine.
learn from it I'm AI learning right now okay um so the plan
so um oh it's okay it builds on top of my AI learning now I
know what not to do see I didn't counter that before so uh
so now that I know to delete that input My AI is simply just
getting stronger.
Alright.
Guys, I'm being bad on purpose.
It's just...
It was for content, guys.
Just to make the video more interesting, guys.
Okay, the momentum needs to take me up here.
Oh, God.
Come on.
Where's my momentum?
Oh, God.
See it won't be as fun if I first try everything right off
the bat It's all about the journey that we're building
together, you know the XP levels we're gaining guys Guys we
were here for a character arc see if the if the hero was If
the hero was max level great at everything right off the bat
then we're not like learning from we're not growing with the
character it'll be too boring uh we got logic crash adoki ai
audio thank you for the super chat thank you thank you so we
gotta like have a journey here and build like the character
arc so you're like on this journey with the streamer as they
improve more and more um in the game and then you're like
cheering them on watching them in their journey to become a
better player because if they're good right off the bat then
like you don't gain anything out of it like you don't want
like a winner right off the bat you want to be there when
they get better and then um go on build build up their
experience and all the skills that they learn over the time
and yeah everyone loves an underdog
all right come on let me through don't worry i'm simply
getting better at this it's all about the hero's journey
exactly because then it'd be too boring if you win all the
time where's the excitement you know how this gonna end if
the person always wins We gotta build up the tension.
Alright, it's okay.
Here we go.
We got this.
We figured it out.
We figured everything.
We know how to...
We played these games before.
We know how to beat the system.
Okay.
Alright.
Now we know how to beat the system.
This is it.
This is the run.
This is the run, guys.
Right here.
We're going to get Isaac back home.
Oh, my god.
This is it.
Isaac, come home, Isaac.
We're going to bring you back to Earth.
This is the run this time.
Right here.
Alright, we're almost there.
This is it.
have a plan.
Okay, that's okay.
The plan includes... That was part of the plan, too.
Losing that leg?
Part of the plan.
Watch this.
Okay, this might not have been... I know this is hard to
believe, but this might not be part of the plan.
I know it's a little hard to believe, but that was...
That was not part of the plan
All right, this is it this that this is it everything is
planned meticulously every movement every input all part of
the plan Right here
Watch this Oh my god, surely he'll surely he'll get out of
my ass surely right sure
that was see that was called a tactical reset guys uh
because this level is very rng one um it wasn't part of the
we got the wrong um generated pathway so we had to do a
tactical reset
so now everything you see every
Pokemon Fire, now you and me Na na na na na na Na na, now
Pokemon Na na na Na Na Na Pokemon Fire Na na Na Na Na Na You
What happened?
What do you mean?
Oh, whoa, no, don't worry, Misty's alright.
Uh, she'll be fine.
Yay, the Water Badge!
Let's go!
Pure, you need at least one Pokemon to challenge me.
Where did my Pikachu go?
Alright, Pikachu.
This is your time to shine.
Is he...
Pikachu, do your thing, Pikachu.
It's no fair your Pokemon.
Oh, yes, as we all know, Thunder is so good against Rock.
Alright, first off, how the fuck do I get out over this guy?
Oh no, how is my Pikachu gonna make it?
Oh no.
My first obstacle.
Why is this not bicycle accessible?
Oh god.
Pikachu, please.
Okay, wait.
No!
Let's go backwards.
It's okay, it's okay.
figuring it out too much rock all right pikachu do your
thing pikachu you're ahead of me you can make it past me ah
uh little 2012 dokey does not breed uh it's not so different
from 2026 dokey but uh how did i get past that so naturally
oh pikachu i need you to be ahead of me.
Team Doki blasting off again.
Oh, look.
There's Misty.
She seems fine.
She's all head now.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh!
Maybe a little too much head.
Alright, boy.
Continue my legacy.
Oh, he's useless.
All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
Don't worry.
My wife will get the kid in the divorce, and then I'll be
free.
Oh, God, it's fine.
Oh, no, no.
He's struck the frontal lobe.
The sparrow hit the frontal lobe.
All right.
It's okay.
We got this.
Round first, round one.
First try.
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
Make sure, please.
Please.
If there was any time to use Thunderbolt, this is it.
Oh, my God.
We're ping-ponging with Star Me right now.
Star Me, Pink.
Oh, wow.
The momentum stops.
Oh, my God.
Hello?
Star Me?
Star Me.
Come on.
Start me.
Please.
You can't softlock me.
Not now.
Oh my god.
I did.
I bugged it.
How is this possible?
Oh, it's fine.
We still have her.
It's just a flesh wound.
We still have our legs.
That's it.
I'm moving forward.
This is actually good.
for me, too.
This is very good for me.
Very slowly.
Alright, there.
Nice.
Obstacle gone.
This is very good for me because I can dodge all of this now
that I don't have arms.
Alright, Pikachu.
This is it.
Where's Pikachu?
Alright.
Okay, no, no.
Pikachu, no.
No, this is not good.
Pikachu, Pikachu.
Pikachu!
No!
Okay, there you go.
Alright, nice.
Where's the... Oh, it's right here.
Oh, no!
Oh, it's okay.
It's just my son.
Oh, Team Art Blast on Speedo of Light.
Surrounding now.
Or prepare to fight.
Yeah, that's right.
Alright, there's the gym badge.
I went to Diglet Cave now.
Oh, look.
Now we're matching.
Me and my son are now matching, guys.
Oh, goodbye, son.
The Diglets will now raise you.
Thank God.
Oh, this is not good.
Don't worry, I have the power of bike.
I'll body block all of this.
Bye, Timmy.
Oh, no.
Abandoned Pokemon Center.
Oh, wait, there's Timmy.
We just found this poor Charizard.
Knee arms.
No!
I'm a loser!
It actually got off my butt Everything that could go wrong
went wrong That's a little bit aimless of you To God people
with no arms losers That's fucked up That's it I'm canceling
Pokemans all right it's okay wait we have all arms intact
this is a good sign guys that's a very good sign all arms
are intact for this journey oh my god where every limb is
intact we don't know about misty though but hey i'm all
right
don't let that police woman tell you what to do you're so
right oh no oh no pikachu please need to get off this ramp.
I need you to go.
No, Pikachu.
Don't run away.
Don't worry.
Thunder is weak against rock, Pikachu.
Do not be afraid.
He's like fighting back right now.
Don't worry.
As we all know, we're type advantages, Pikachu.
Thunder is weak.
It's strong against rock.
Maybe the bad.
Yeah.
I knew it.
Thank God, Oh, God.
Oh, do not be afraid.
Oh.
Oh, my ass.
I took him.
My son.
Just keep going on.
My son has...
Oh.
My son might not have arms anymore.
Please.
I just want to be one more level.
Please I'm an adult now Oh people are like Oh my let's play
Oh it's like all the 2012 let's plays Oh No I have no arms
What's the point?
It's okay It's okay I won't let the police woman tell me
what to do I don't need no arms I don't need no son All I
need is me Oh god Oh god.
Oh god.
I just I just wanna be the very best.
How did my song?
Anything can go wrong.
That's alright.
Here we go.
We got this.
Alright, Pikachu.
Do your thing, Pikachu.
I realize the pokeball is what's leading the Pikachu at you
like uh i think he's like following the pokeball right is he
following me or the pokeball i can't tell no he's following
me so that was the one time he just did not want to go into
the gym i guess oh god please don't break your neck please
don't break your neck no no i pressed eject no no it's just
it's just not for me it was just his wipe out tat a white
belt.
Surely, surely I can beat this level.
It's white belt.
Surely, right?
How hard can it be?
Oh!
My, okay, wait, wait, wait.
I think I got it.
I think I got the system.
Oh, surely can't be that hard.
Please, just one level.
Just one level.
I can do this.
I can do one.
Oh, wait.
I beat the...
Wait.
What?
When did I...
Wait, guys.
When...
Look, it says I beat Dead Space.
Who am I to argue about that?
Who am I to argue against the game?
It said I...
It said I beat it.
All right, let's try Subject.
We take those.
Exactly.
What the fuck?
It has its own cutscene?
Wake up.
Oh my god.
It has its own cutscene.
The fuck?
Bro.
Wait, this is the most...
Advanced looking one.
This most polished one I've seen.
There's shading on here.
These guys.
It's caused by a major system error.
It's triple A gaming in my happy wheels.
Monster is short.
The doctor gave me the command to seek for a healthy
subject.
You need to gather data from your brain.
You understand they need one with a working brain, right?
Doctors froze themselves.
I only am allowed to talk.
when I found an active subject.
Which I have now you are here.
Where's the yellow paint?
You see this is a 2012 game, so yellow paint wasn't there
yet.
Press the defrost button, and let's go to doctors.
The world will be saved.
Alright.
That'd be that bad.
Uh.
Yes.
Alright, I've defrosted.
now what I will throw you up there jump on my hands all
right um bro this is a cuphead tutorial and my cup I might
my instructions on oh there we go there we go May or may not
have Am I a cuphead journalist right now?
Like, what's going on?
What happened?
Which one is the most important from the others?
Um.
The sun.
Oh.
Uh, the fridge.
Thank God I have more than one desk.
Which one is the most different from the others?
Shark!
Oh!
Okay, we're fine.
And which one is most different from the other areas?
Don't say fuck you see fuck is a very bad and I can't report
PT because YouTube sends it.
So I'm jealous.
Wisa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This seems like easy.
This seems beatable.
This seems dokey coded.
Oh, I thought I was going to get crushed right there.
Thank God.
A level made for me.
hey how do i i'm not supposed to i'm blocked by oh no oh no
hey no no no no bar where do i go i thought this level was
made for me life critical system malfunction yellow card i
need to find the yellow card where am I oh my god oh my god
oh my god there's my yellow paint there's my there it is
thank the Lord for yellow paint okay I got the yellow card
life functions critical which one is the most different from
the the future begins with you me oh um bird oh oh i don't
oh that's not great wait there's laura in my happy wheels
okay wait wait i didn't see what she said no my leg i went
by so fast
all right you're still here
oh okay finally yeah that's me also sapphire thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you yo bro from 2012 check
out this funny dokey bear youtuber she's so awesome funny
when she gets pwn i think it was super chat sapphire thank
you thank you you're not going anywhere until you tested my
follow me to the room and take the pill okay yummy yummy who
wants the little pill i do i do i want the pill all right
can't be that bad a stranger tells me to take it okay but
what are my other options
all right until you have tested it do i just wait he'll get
more tired right it's just you me and the pill i feel like
i'm not supposed to take the pill guys
pill.
Take the pill.
What do I do?
Okay, I took the pill.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, I'm... You are here.
Oh, where do I have to go now?
Oh, no.
What a disaster to test up.
I'm having a bad trip guys oh no i'm tripping out to do one
plus one your answer critical two two yes oh no wait is fire
safe oh fire safe oh guys maybe i should have followed the
oh oh guys i did it
Well, at least we know fire was safe.
Guys, guys, I think I can do this now.
I think I've leveled up after everything.
I think I can do this now.
I think after everything we've been through.
Well, I think I've done it.
I see it.
I need to know how it ends, Doki.
Don't worry.
up.
I think this is it.
After everything I've been through, I don't care.
It's, oh.
This is it.
I can grab it this time.
I figured it out.
I've learned it.
This is going to be pure cinema when I finally hit it.
Okay.
Nice.
Get parried.
The final arc.
No!
I will conquer I will get my son back Here you go Right here
I have a plan I didn't get worse guys I didn't get worse in
this game I'm making progress There you go I told you There
you go Okay as long as I don't get hit by the axe It should
be fine
Okay, okay, okay, I don't, okay, that was a little too
close, but it's okay.
Everything is fine.
All right.
This is it.
Here we go.
All right.
And then we gotta take him over here.
Boom.
All right, he hurt himself in confusion.
Oh, God, that was close.
all right not getting grabbed here and then here we go watch
this
oh my god oh my god i got one my one my arms are no
but i i grabbed it i grabbed it no look instructions was
unclear he said grab it he didn't say he didn't say have to
be both arms look now that i know i've gained xp guys i've
gained xp i now know it's both arms i know i now see it
didn't say use both hands to grab it it just said grab it
This is it.
We're right there.
We're right there at the finish line.
Oh, no.
No.
It still hits me.
Don't worry.
We will save our son.
Our son will come back to us, guys.
And then my wife won't leave me.
We have to do this for our marriage.
For some reason, she was really mad that we lost...
Okay, we lost our son.
This is a group F.
see raising a child is a team effort it's not solely relying
on one parent or the other so the kid is lost and it's both
parents fault both parents no no oh my god it's okay it's
alright we're gonna kid oh oh it's okay it's okay we just
made a new friend it takes exactly takes a village to raise
a child all right here it just gives me more momentum oh
that is extra wait now i'm a little worried that all right
no we're fine oh it's fine everything is fine everything is
awesome everything is cool when you're part oh okay maybe
okay out of everything that kills me it was that all right
okay that's That's fine.
That's fine.
Good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
In 2012, I can't wait for Tokey Bird Minecraft Lucky Blocks
Open.
Out of everything that was, that's what kills me.
A piece of glass.
Who would have known a glass sharder through the head could
kill you?
I feel like, I feel like there should have been a warning
about that.
How would anyone know, huh?
Holy shit, that guy exploded.
bicycles are dangerous.
This is it.
This is the run.
Guys.
Okay.
Alright.
Made it.
Oh.
Okay.
No glass.
No glass here.
I know.
I feel like I should sue him.
I should sue them for that.
Oh.
Alright.
For real this time.
Right here.
eject eject where's my arm go grab grab oh very fully okay
you'll have to perform a sneak attack via the roof when I
say now you must let go not second too early or too late you
must trust me I am the voice or Morgan Freeman right ready?
Not yet?
Now!
Think wrong!
What do you mean, take me?
Oh!
Oh my god.
We fucking... I... I told... We did it, my friend.
We saw the end.
We fucking did it.
I told you.
I told you guys.
We can do it.
do it you know one believed in me but i believed in myself
and that's all i needed i told you will see the end of
taking three i just had to gain the xb i yeah excited this
thing grows an axe afterwards we take those guys we fucking
take those look at that every level first try Welcome back,
2012.
Alright, I'm going to call it here, guys.
What a nice stream of nostalgia that we had today.
Had a great time trying out Happy Wheels for the first time.
Like I said, I've never played this game before.
I've always watched Let's Players play it.
But, you know, it was nice going through nostalgia, checking
out the game for the first time myself now that I am an
adult.
Now it's my turn.
They passed the wheel to me.
They passed the gauntlet.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
I need to get some food.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know what to get today, but I'm going to go grab
some food.
It was nice nostalgia trip.
It was nice checking out all the different levels, playing
various different levels and mechanics too.
Like just trying all the different characters.
Saka, they give us Super Chat, they can't wait for Q-Wap
next time.
They give us Super Chat, we're never seeing the end of that
game.
Like, I would be surprised if we wouldn't get as far as one
meter.
Yeah, it's my turn to be a silly adult.
But, thank you all for watching.
I'm going to head off now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around and get that blood flowing.
From me, head to Ben, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye-bye.
Bye.